hallo mein besuchern herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen video ich habe
euch bei twitter gefragt ob irgendwelche
fragen an mich habt und die wollte ich
heute im video mal wieder beantworten
allerdings wollte ich vorher noch über
zwei kleine sachen kunst reden das geht
aber wirklich extrem schnell die erste
sache ist etwas was ich sehr viele
gefragt hatten uns zwar mutter warum
kamen gestern kein video wird sie stellt
sie selbst ihr sohn james du bist ein
youtube
du bist etwas machen ich weiß nämlich
wetter seien auf dem gesundheitlichen
zustand beschwert aber irgendwie waren
das wohl die vorzeichen von irgendeiner
grippe erkältung was auch immer ich
gerade habe also eher mäßigend wie hey
es dann kalt man darf sie zu die
nasenschleimhäute halt so als dieses
ding hier der tür auch weh und ich
spreche da ganz anderen tonlage also ich
bin einfach derzeit erkältet deswegen
hab ich mir gestern gesagt okay ich
könnte mir eine pause und verletzte das
ist ein grund warum gestern kein video
gehabt die zweite sache ist youtube hat
abonnenten gelöscht sehr sehr viele
amerikanische und auch deutsche youtube
an da schon zu löschen
vielleicht sollte ich es gar nicht sagen
viele leute haben dazu schon videos
gemacht allerdings muss man ja immer
auch die eigenen abonnenten darauf
aufmerksam machen weil ich sehr viele
kommentare bekommen habe
mein abo an dich wurde irgendwie von
youtube gelöscht aber ich bin ich gar
nicht inaktiv hey ich bin wild die
parolen von einem kanal nur weil ich an
meinem laptop nicht mehr aktiv bin
allerdings bin ich die ganze zeit noch
am handy auch deinen kanal gegangen
irgendwie youtube gestern vorgestern
wohl sehr sehr viele interaktive
abonnenten von den kanälen entfernen das
baden von by paying wieder her dazu auch
wieder gemacht um die 600.000 bei mir
waren es irgendwie 10.000 jetzt oder so
natürlich ist 10.000 im vergleich zu
600.000 nicht viel und 10.000 von meiner
kompletten anzahl der abonnenten dass
ihr 17 millionen ist es auch eher
weniger wenn man sich aber überlegen wie
viele menschen eigentlich 10.000 leute
sind so das ist irgendwie ein sechstel
von einem kompletten stadion die einfach
mal so entfernt wurden youtube dazu dann
hat das statement raus
auch noch dominik raid assassinen
gelassen youtube star xu qing enthält
ein mobil chevron barrymore so nach dem
motto ok da ist youtube oder anders
gesagt stellt euch vor ihr habt eine
website wo leute irgendwie versammelt
köln und auf einmal werden einfach fans
gelöscht man sagen die betreiber der
website jo irgendwie wurden heute fans
von euch gelöscht wir wissen nicht woran
das liegt aber wir arbeiten dran und ich
gehört die scheiße ich werde halt nicht
ganz so aus also youtube deshalb auch
schon sehr viele leute gesagt aber das
ist eure website ihr müsst doch wissen
was da passiert ist also youtube hat
schon öfters so gemacht dass sie in der
tv abonnenten entfernt haben was ja auch
an sich kein schlimmer schritt ist und
als er eigentlich also etwas gutes tut
so man kriegt keine inaktiven abonnenten
mehr alle blöd leute werden empfehlen
allerdings wurden wenn die auch so viele
leute empfehlen die sich nach den
beschwerden wegen wieso hast du mich
denn verletzt abonnenten ich denke doch
dass bei youtube die könnt ihr hätten
nichts gegen youtube an der stelle mit
denen hatte ich in letzter zeit schon
genug stress video entfernt
unangemessene inhalte steht eishockey
dinge allerdings geht doch einfach mal
bitte auf meinen kanal und checkt aus ob
irgendwie das abo noch da ist weil
vielleicht werde ich ja gerade erst mal
bei euch auf der youtube startseite
angezeigt allerdings nicht unter euren
abonnenten uploads oder und empfehlungen
und ihr seid gar nicht mehr runter von
meinem kanal und auch so wenigen welche
freunde kennen die vielleicht jetzt in
letzter zeit nicht aktiv an und ging wie
das abgelöscht wurde oder so sagt es
denen einfach mal dass sie das
kontrollieren sollen weil youtube hat
wirklich unnormal viele leute entfernt
hat und jetzt fangen wir mit den fragen
welches wort würde dein ganzes leben
beschreiben entweder spontanität oder
workflow also ich versuche wirklich ja
das sind schon zwei fertig druckkopf was
hältst du von der rost yourself
challenge bei der rost josef scherrer
geht es darum dass man sich selber quasi
hoch nimmt und gegen sich selber quasi
ein diss aufnimmt sei es mit musik
hinterlegt oder einfach nur ein lahmer
oder irgendwie sowas stopp es muss schon
mit musik unterlegt sein dass er schon
cooler in der tat finde ich total coole
aktion so was hatte ich selber auch
schon geplant ist gibt sehr viele leute
die irgendwie dieses gegen youtuber
geschrieben haben sich untereinander
bieten allerdings und jemand der dich
selber geht ist dann das ist eigentlich
so ganz genau ihr prinzip auf meinem
kanal dass ich mich selber fertig machen
wenig ist das tatsächlich sehr traurig
guck mal da nimmt man die auf toilette
auch direkt verschwindet die sonne da
vorne geht es wortgleich mit der
belichtung wurde so ich hätte auch war
boxer aus der challenge zu machen
allerdings warten dass er kelly und so
relativ professionell ist wirklich mit
studioproduktion ich will das einfach so
machen wie man die meiner eher verbal
der parodie
als ich das ganze wieder so ein bisschen
noch gene also wenn ihr da bock drauf
habe dass man bitte den bewertungen
darum schreibt über die kommentare
vielleicht irgendwelche lions oder so
die steht nicht selber rappen kann und
dann kommt das vielleicht die tage
lieber verdursten oder erfrieren ich
hasse langsam methode also ich kann das
nicht aus erfahrung sagen weil ich mir
vielleicht sehen noch nie gestorben
das war wieder unser kommentar lukas
fisch und verdursten nur der frieren
kann ich mich jetzt nicht richtig
entscheiden allerdings will ich lieber
erfrieren weil ich glaube da ist es so
dass man so langsam einschläft und
einfachsten ist es so du merkst richtig
wie ich will der friert nehmen ab ich
wenn ich dich in der stadt sehe dich in
einen sack stecken und ich mit nach
hause nehmen
da willst du deine freunde aus der
schulzeit beziehungsweise seid ihr noch
befreundet ich vermisse dich niemand aus
der schulzeit und die leute die man
vermissen würde mit denen dass man immer
noch befreundet also das ist so in der
schule ist man in einer stufe in der
elften und zwölften klasse bei mir waren
es irgendwie mit 120 anderen leuten und
mit zehn leuten würde ich sagen weil ich
richtig gut befreundet markante zahlen
noch so 20 andere leute wo man sagt okay
das sind freunde von mir und darauf sei
50 jahre leute sind bekannte dem blatt
man dann mal unter 50 leute sind der
meinung die ich komme gar nicht auf 120
wenn ich die ganze zeit so aufzählung
allerdings ist es einfach wirklich so
spätestens ein jahr wie man die schule
beendet hat man gar keinen kontakt mit
dem auch sei zu seiner kleinen gruppe
von leuten und so was bei mir halt auch
ist mit deinen namen zufrieden also luca
oder würdest du gerne an das heißt ich
heiße luca mit vornamen und tele2 tele2
zeitpunkt wo ich schon getauft wurde war
nun kann auch kein reiner männlich und
habe ich will aber eigentlich recht
zufrieden mit meinem namen weil es ist
halt jetzt nicht so was wie max
sebastian felix hans oder sowie hat
jeder in die heißt ja was soll man
machen wenn man zwei stunden zu spät
kommt ich würde die zeit zurückdrehen
kommst du zu den video des 2016 in köln
ich komme definitiv zu den video des
2016 in köln ich kann noch nicht sagen
ob ich zu den anderen videos kommen
werde
wird ja auch noch in münchen hamburg
berlin warum wieso sind gibt's in köln
kann ich noch nicht sagen ob ich zu dem
komme werde und ich kann euch gar nicht
sagen ob ich bei dem wieder der 2016
köln sogar schon da haben werde ich weiß
wie wir denken sich jetzt irgendwas als
rosig million abonnenten hier natürlich
hast du nord stunde ja ich werde auch
nie so blutig denn haben arm bin ich den
bescheid
es war die letzten drei jahre auch so
dass sie auf mich zugekommen sind
meinten jogi viele auf dem kampflosen zu
haben blabla no es war halt immer so
weit autogramm ich schon habe ich mich
bisher immer ich bin war krank weil man
halt so viele menschen umarmen sondern
alles möglich und ich weiß halt nach dem
august schreibe ich zwei wochen beim
personen- und wenn ich da krankl ist und
der tod für mich deswegen werde ich
wahrscheinlich einfach nur zum video der
ist gehen so ein bisschen chillen
rumlaufen natürlich mit ein paar leuten
autogramme und fotos machen wenn ihr
mich seht aber ich werde jetzt nicht
stehen an so einem tisch und jedoch arme
dann acht stunden autogramme geben weil
es das klinik hin doch wie geht's dir
eigentlich also jetzt gerade sitze ich
auf der toilette gefällt sie mir das
übrigens nicht glaubt ich sitze hier
gerade tatsächlich auf dem klo aber die
frage was das ja auch behindert hallo
und keiner stieg in mir geht es
eigentlich gerade sehr gut allerdings
bin nicht krank erkältet und deswegen
jetzt mehr scheiße deswegen sich
wahrscheinlich auch gerade ultra fertig
aus total verschwitzt war ich nur im
spitzen bin und auch ich weiß nicht also
es tut mir leid dass gestern ein video
kam aber ich wollte eigentlich nichts
machen aber ich mache jetzt einfach mal
fragen was du vor irgendwann nur noch
real life auf dem kanal zu bringen ich
hatte eigentlich gar nichts vom bezug
auf youtube wie so oft die frage
gestellt wie soll es weitergehen was
irgendwie dann machst du das noch blabla
ich lasse einfach auf mich zukommt jetzt
habe ich einen trailer video oder so was
was ich jetzt gerade machen so fragen
beantworten als halt auf gaming
allerdings habe ich noch nicht sagen
dass ich in einem jahr auch marie leicht
machen werde weil es kann sein dass ich
nun ja wieder
welche ponyspiele spielen werden oder so
weil ich will youtube ich finde youtube
macht meistens sind wenn man das macht
worauf man bock hat und sonst nicht
kannst du für zehn sekunden deine zunge
rausstrecken und gleichzeitig welche art
von videos produziert du am liebsten
geht eigentlich ein herr mit der frage
nicht gerade schon ein bisschen
fälschlich beantwortet habe zwar elab
videos derzeit allerdings kann ich halt
nicht sagen was wir am liebsten spaß
machen wird im jahr aber jetzt gerade
moment relief videos und sowas wie auch
videos von euch reagieren und so ein
schwachsinn alte meinung spring break
als ich den trade sie brad pitt ich weiß
nicht ob break auch irgendwie so ein
synonym dafür ist für großbritannien
vernetzt die eu aber was ich will hier
keine großen politischen äußerungen
machen da habe ich mich ja immer schon
vor gehoben das haben andere youtuber
sehr gute der vergangenheit unter schau
gestellt allerdings sagen ich hab mal
dazu ich glaube großbritannien wird
demnächst noch bewusst werden was das
für eine große scheiße ist damit würde
ich das video jetzt beendet meine damen
und herren ich muss raus aus diesem
zimmer ihre ich hoffe allerdings hat das
video irgendwie trotzdem gefallen ich
weiß es war jetzt nur so lokal arbeit
über seine krankheit gerade lokal aber
dass youtube abonnenten gelöscht luca
beantwortet noch ein paar fragen damit
das video irgendwie ein bisschen länger
wird vielleicht bei uns jetzt trotzdem
einige ganz cool und schreib mir die
kommentare in der osthälfte challenge
die tage haben wollte und was ich morgen
hochladen soll griechenland manier